and finally new rule stop trying to get
me to watch Tiger King it's not gonna
happen
I already have to watch one bottle
blonde from reality TV and the other
reason I'm not watching tiger king while
sequestering because torturing animals
is what got us into this mess that's the
lesson we keep refusing to learn that
you can't trash the environment
including animals and not have it come
back and kill you two weeks ago I called
out China for reopening their wet
markets and miraculously people from
both sides of the aisle reached out to
say good for you for saying that well
here's another hot take that may not be
as popular America's factory farming is
just as despicable as a wet market and
just as problematic for our health
factory farms have a lot more lobbyists
but ecological time bombs tick the same
Americans should not get to high and
mighty about wet markets while we are
doing this most if not all infectious
diseases are zoonotic meaning they start
in animals and jump to humans aids
likely came from primates someone
butchered a monkey or [ __ ] one or
something they shouldn't been doing with
a monkey mad cow came from cattle eating
cattle which is like feeding a chicken
and omelet just two weeks ago a fatal
strain of bird flu was confirmed in a
commercial turkey flock in South
Carolina
now to fort the corona virus we've been
told to create distance avoid others who
are sick lower stress and exercise are
you surprised that diseases flourish
among animals when they're forced to
live in conditions that are the complete
opposite of all of that they're on top
of each other they can't move they're
stressed out I've seen airport street
luggage better than we treat animals
egg-laying hens are starved and given no
water for weeks to shock their bodies
into molting beaks of chickens are
I could go on have you ever driven by a
high-density feedlot yeesh to get relief
from the stench you have to stick your
nose in an egg salad sandwich and you
think the market in Wuhan is gross you
should visit one of our giant poultry
processing factories but of course you
can't because we have AG gag laws that
make it a crime to report the crime and
it is a crime of animal abuse that goes
on in our food industry you're worried
that the mailman is gorona virus 80% of
pigs have pneumonia when they're
slaughtered because we make them live in
conditions that would make a zombie
vomit and then so they don't die before
we kill them pump them full of
antibiotics that in turn get passed on
to humans that in turn leads to
antibiotic resistant diseases that in
turn leads to us dying from ever
evolving contagions it's 6 degrees of
tainted bacon we're on the cusp of
returning to a pre-antibiotic era where
strep throat was a death sentence let me
put it as basically as I can if we keep
producing food the way we do you're
going to get sick with something
medicine cannot fix you don't have to
care for the sake of the animals I
wouldn't want to mess with anyone's
reputation as a heartless [ __ ] but do
it because animal cruelty leads to human
catastrophe do it because barbecue is
why you've been masturbating for a month
I'd get the [ __ ] away from me with Tiger
king I don't care that he sees the light
at the end
so did Darth Vader there's no such thing
as keeping a wild animal pent up but
treating them well just as zigfried and
what remains of Roy Jo X otic is in
prison partly for killing five
endangered Tigers which are endangered
because of people like him I don't get
why the woke left loves this show so
much and isn't on this guy like pink
sequins people should take their
meandering outrage and focus it on this
issue you keep animals in cages be they
tigers or turkeys and look who winds up
being the prisoner
you